à peine ouvert qui font la queue devant
la porte la Twizy en autopartage arrive
sur la communauté d'agglomération de 50
ans en Yvelines et séduit déjà les
futurs utilisateurs j'ai beaucoup d'amis
qui sont dans la ville mais pas très
proche de chez moi ça me permettrait
d'aller voir d'aller voir plus
rapidement je sais pas trop cher
financièrement parlant et voilà quoi
pour 29 centimes par minute pratique si
on fait qu'un trajet de 2-3 minutes le
temps qu'à faire au lieu de prendre le
bus et puis 1,90 € pour réserver votre
Twizy rendez-vous sur Internet ou sur
votre smartphone pour vérifier la
disponibilité et le taux de charge des
véhicules l'autre façon plus directe
cette fois vous rendre sur une zone de
garage Twizy sur les communes de
Guyancourt Montigny
Voisins-le-Bretonneux et trappes et muni
de votre badge débloquez la voiture pas
d'abonnement seulement des frais
d'adhésion de 15 euros pour obtenir
votre passe Twizy on ne paye que lors de
l'utilisation lorsque je roule là je
suis à 29 centime la minute
plafonner à 11,90 € de l'heure si je
suis en arrêt temporaire comme là c'est
à dire que personne d'autre que moi ne
peut l'utiliser mais il est en
stationnement à ce moment là je suis à
10 centimes la minute et puis en plus si
je veux le réserver j'ai un forfait
réservation de 1 euro pour 15 minutes de
réservation les cinq premières minutes
sont gratuites après le passage du badge
sur le code barre et pour ce service
d'autopartage il faut être titulaire
d'un permis voiture depuis plus de 2 ans